and it kind of exciting but not as
exciting I feel like as a normal apple
product introduction well we already
knew about this right i mean that's
something i just saw the wall street
journal flash is gonna cost between
three forty nine and ten thousand well
tell me something I didn't know ten
thousand thousand was on the high end of
the estimates by estimate but there is a
bob eats dream from this morning please
ok ok we're on point with that yeah I
knew we were talking about 10,000 of
Bloomberg story and Alex said even if it
uses almost $31 where the gold right
that's still gonna be the price since
there are professional athletes and
there are Europeans Chinese yeah yeah
more to the point the Chinese consumer I
mean there are huge pins now I tweeted
her gold fact this morning I'm stunned
by which i right I heard you tell Betty
that only 31 dollars worth of 18 karat
gold will go into the watch no one node
1 gram is worth $31 oh so it depends on
how many grams they use so if they use
say 30 grams which is I've been hearing
a little bit about as well it'll be
about a thousand dollars but especially
I'm rough math but it is special gold is
a two because it's actually supposed to
be thicker it supposed to be better than
the standard usual goal so it doesn't
good goal I'll busted like my rings do
when I hit them again something social
but either way if you're looking about
30 33 tons if you produce say a million
a month if you produce a million a month
I mean that's not that much gold and the
scheme of things alright so but ten
thousand dollars it's unlikely that
someone's gonna really isn't it isn't it
Sam I mean it's a big status purchase
there and I'm sure they're only
expecting a few people to actually go
out and pay for that what's amazing to
me is that we have a product now that
has a range of prices from three hundred
and fifty dollars to ten grand I can't
think of another product that costs so
differently you know as such a wide
range of MSR yes yeah well non drugs and
when I was sort of a scouring the gold
world about hazen's gonna really move
the gold market Frank combs of us global
investors said you know no it's not
gonna hurt the supply factor a demand
factor but it is sort of a big deal in
that it validates gold is a luxury
symbol if you go around with it it says
something I mean it's a watch you might
have to replace a watch in a few years
right so graphic sort of explaining so
have it ready to in this graphic so but
18 carat I see because of living is
about seven person 18 carat about
thirty-five percent gold and China I
should point out is actually eating up
18 carat gold items like crazy
especially under among younger people
and China and India are responsible for
the bulk of most gold buying in the
world so it's really will its appeal to
that at the end of the day get back to
your point man I I watched the
proceedings and I felt similarly that
you know everything they were
introducing and germs are the features
of the watch and the third party apps
all very expected and all things that
you could probably do with your phone
nothing very watch specific here so it
still remains to be a question as to
whether or not this is gonna move in
huge numbers like the phone and the ipad
did or will be something else who do you
think the market is this people that
would spend more money for a better job
own is it people that would want to buy
a son toe watch you know that tells you
all these special details I don't think
that anybody that Apple is trying to
reach has been thinking about other
smartwatches or for that matter even
other Fitness fans may be a little bit
of crossover with the jaw bones and the
fitbit's of the world but this is a much
more mainstream audience right and so
they don't know about Android where they
don't know about some know they're going
to see this and as far as they're
concerned this is the first SmartWatch
that they know about part of my question
though is what this is due to some kind
of replacement cycle I mean we've seen
the ipad really struggle because people
do tend to not want to upgrade their
iPad when they run out of memory when
they run out of their their their OS
nobody's gonna want to spend three
hundred and fifty dollars are you doing
your iphone and you do with your macbook
so because there's economic
infrastructure with your phone and your
carrier right that encourages you to
upgrade subsidizes the cost of that
that's not happening here with the watch
so it to your point yeah it's a little
bit on the beauty of a watch is that
it's one of the one of the few things
that you can buy and you know you're
gonna hold on to it pretty much forever
I mean longer than a car maybe even
longer than a house and yet patek
philippe doesn't come out every year
with a new watch that says this one is
so much better than the previous
portuguese repeater china that you had
because now it has a flyback mechanism
that nobody had before those watches
tend to last longer because there isn't
that much evolution presumably there are
going to be new Apple watches if not
every year of
a couple of years and people might start
to wonder oh wait mine can't do all the
new things that the new one can do right
and so do you have an upgrade cycle and
you have people not buying it at all
because they don't want to be forced
into spending multiple hundreds of
dollars every that's the big question
leads to an interesting debate you know
Paul could Oscar and I were talking
about whether or not rolex or IWC will
now add digital features to their
compete with that I'm honored or will
they somehow move into some sort of
third party supplier arrangement and
we've provide bands you know Hermes
could do that we Tong could do that they
could become suppliers sort of Apple
watch ready players